tweet 17 seconds let's do it
my eyes look tired do they it's 3am
it slept for about four hours it'll get
ya
all right let's go let's do this fable
perfect doc
let me know if i need to change the
audio at all anybody
if i need to turn it up or whatever you
guys let me know sounds great to me so
far
oh i i have been to a few of the xbox
press conferences in person
and one of them made me actually scream
[Laughter]
it was pretty dope
another countdown love to see it
watching the xbox and bethesda
conference
okay let's go let's do this what is it
come at me
20 years that's how long xbox has been
with us
i like expected phil i was caught off
guard seeing todd howard
who i also like was it crossing my
fingers from my favorites to return
hoping for a few surprises most of all
around the world come together and
celebrate what games mean to all of us
and i think you know this past year
they've meant even more
thank you for being with us today thank
you for the support you give us
and one another xbox is turning 20.
and i wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
the friendships we've had
that whole time at bethesda we believe
video games do one thing better than
anything else
they transport us through art and
technology
there's real magic when you step into a
new world and can make it your own
we've traveled the worlds of elder
scrolls of fallout are they going to
stop
it for the first time in over 25 years
we're creating a new universe ah with
starfield they are
set hundreds of years in our future it's
an epic
about hope our shared humanity and
answering
our greatest mystery it's a game we've
dreamt of playing
and it wasn't until now that we have the
hardware the technology and the team the
engine who's hard to work at home
pretty neat to make that dream a reality
we're excited to finally share
our first in-game teaser and something
to look forward well this is a good
start
if you ask me
[Laughter]
constellation starship frontiers
[Music]
this could have been 25 years in the
making someone could have pitched this
that long ago
they say the wonder is not that the
field of
stars is so vast but that we have
measured it
you're part of constellation now part
of our family what you've found
it's the key to unlocking everything
[Music]
i mean this looks beautiful but of
course
it's very empty out there
that's why we're here
[Music]
was that a release date
because that would be the boldest thing
in the world why on earth would you
announce
okay
if you say so late 2022
damn all right that's that seems so far
in advance for bethesda
wow xbox exclusive confirmed which
i feel like we knew anyway it will be
free day one you'd love to see it
damn there you go awesome to share with
you for the very first don't know what
the game is
anticipated games in the world from todd
howard and the team at bethesda games
studios
a groundbreaking game and yes it's
exclusive
welcome to the xbox and bethesda game
showcase
i am so excited and proud to be here
today celebrating
games because although it's been an
incredibly tough year
i am grateful that games have been such
an important source of joy
and connection we are committed
to forging the next era of gaming
conjuring worlds never before i don't
like the slow zoom
unlocking play across all devices thank
you please delivering the power of games
to everyone and now
we get to share that quest with bethesda
not just as partners but as one team
united in bringing the very best games
to more people
everywhere so today we get to reveal
more of what's to come do it we have an
amazing show no
i don't even know what if you did it
every single console title you'll see
today is optimized
for xbox series x and s
offering next gen performance speed and
features
features we get to work with the best
studios
on earth next is something
truly riveting the latest entry in the
haunting an evocative franchise created
by gsc
game world stalker 2. cool
coming first to xbox series consoles and
pc
this will be a true next-gen experience
targeting 4k resolution and ray tracing
it's a very cool stuff let's take a look
at what you'll get to play when it
launches
next year i'm not a fan of her body
language but
body presenting's weird i looked super
weird when i started to
okay well maybe it's just me
[Music]
gotta
it's kind of nostalgic
um
[Music]
in australia watching in three
conferences
with allergies ongoing
um yeah i did it
[Music]
pretty much my whole life so i
feel like it again
foreign
damn
it's very death stranding wait why don't
you have a baby in that thing
it won't work as well if you don't have
a baby inside
it's cool
yes jacob this is stalker 2 yeah
again apologies for the allergies happen
a lot of streams happening again
do my best
didn't expect that in this trailer
foreign
damn that that looks really good i mean
this whole thing
when it comes to games even though i
love horror games that is going to
terrify me
let's do it
i think pedro said what's a stalker or
what circle why should i care
stoker is like a pretty hardcore
this face
looked like in terms of animation
incredible but sort of low res that was
very strange
foreign
very pretty very much stalker i don't
feel like i saw anything that made me go
what is this video game yet
oh another release date all right sweet
wonder if i'll do that every time
this is 100 rebuilding the game
when was the last time you saw written
in any numbers um
[Music]
i'm it don't worry about it you're here
yeah scotty uh getting me getting a 2021
release date would be nice
you can hold out for that put that on
the most
wanted
come on
buckle up buttercups we've got
one shot let's make it count
over here that's a lot of personal
zombies on screen
i've heard about that ever since dead
writing
one of my first wallpapers i remember
having like a dead rising volcano
the amount of zombies you could get on
screen at one time with that game when i
was telling all my friends in school
who did not care about dead rising about
dead rising all the time
it was the first time that i had a
girlfriend
she said to me we were in art class and
i was talking about dead rising
and she went you know i pretend to care
but i just don't
shut the [ __ ] i up talking about video
games and i was like oh
yeah people probably don't care about
this thing that i care about a lot
[Music]
oh my gosh it's avalanche
[Music]
i love you
[Music]
what what is this going to be
[Music]
oh so it's probably is that here
[Music]
interesting
okay damn i will absolutely buy
avalanche
working on that that's was that already
announced that's neat
[Music]
contraband
ah
oh my god stop an eel wind blows from
beyond the horizon
a new danger
[Music]
now to save the pirate life oh this
isn't gonna work for some reason like my
australian internet browser is a life of
trash
oh didn't realize we had company
interesting captain sparrow
oh that's cool but i suspect you already
knew that
because of the treasure jack storm a
darkness
followed in here and if it's not stopped
this world will sink into shadow
this seahorse i shouldn't do this right
now i really want to know more about
that like is it
a new body about this
we'll figure it out off the street so
called
steve's thieves okay so this is gonna be
a question
let's see mermaids
legion of dead angry pirates
oh yes and now one davy jones
that's [ __ ] cool
i believe that now is the perfect time
to use these cannons
is not actually a world without
what's his faces to face the truth
nothing lasts forever destroy that
[Music]
i mean i again i love seafood it's such
a fun game it's day one
that's such a good time this is this
very smart
sea of thieves i bring me that horizon
[Music]
very cool
so i imagine that is effectively going
to be inside of oh it's pretty sweet
i would have expected it to be but nice
to have the confirmation june 22nd i
will [ __ ] with that yes please and thank
you
oh damn
if you haven't played yakuza you should
that's all i'm gonna say
y'all cause it's a good time hey how's
it going
let's do this they are really fun games
i've recommended them to so many people
and i don't think i've ever had anyone
be like
this he's done
[Music]
time to call a friend
cool guy
happy birthday
this is also a very good trailer because
it
showcases the humor which is part of
what makes yakuza so awesome
there's actually max sobel that's uh
that got me into yakuza i believe if i
remember correctly i think
they are really fun oh my god you're
right june 22nd is really soon
oh battlefield
i am really about this single player
campaign even though i know i shouldn't
expect it
um i just got a battlefield through them
really well but attention
do whatever you can to secure the
sectors
it's so nuts man whenever you see
battlefield footage you're like oh wait
i can do that
and i feel like i do that pretty
frequently or at least i did with the
old games i feel like i
haven't lived many of the video
i think i said this when i was going
over that trailer like those battlefield
moments
only in battlefield they call it and
that's absolutely a thing you can
the set pieces that you can make happen
in multiplayer are so
cool and ridiculous
that level is very pretty that's the
blade runnery one
the storms are really cool too
oh man i don't know that i'd be getting
in an elevator
in a situation like that though can we
maybe hold up on that a bit
damn
so the perspective from the trailer that
rules
wing suit very cool
you know i saw somebody was saying that
you can use the wing suits to your
advantage in storms
i will i will enter the next era
that would not be easy for a video game
to do a multiplayer game to have a
rocket ship take off
not as a cinematic
yeah yeah i'm into it yeah i'm super
into it
um having a pre-alpha tag in the top
left is not a negative
uh oh yeah so yes how was your day what
is it
you know i have something to share why
is this my birthday i'm having a baby
you said did you see the free outfit tag
on the top left corner
that's not like a typical aaa it's just
that video games take a really long time
to make
and thus are in free alpha for a really
long time and will be until right before
they release that isn't a bad thing
[ __ ] yes dude august now you're saying
this a lot too
but back at you i can't wait to play
that game too
so father showcases me being like [ __ ]
look i'll look at all these things that
i'm going to consume and i'm scared
[Music]
look at all these gadgets the mind is
the final frontier of humanity
i'm ready for anything
it it's really impressive how much it
looks like the first psychonauts while
also
obviously being justice
[Music]
modern at the same time like they just
kept that odd style so
consistently the fate of them and they
would have had like team tone
it's not like the exact same people
obviously
but i'm afraid that means
[Music]
shout out to them
saw you buddy we know you're having a
good day
this is a mission about the fate of the
world
can you do that yes if i can find some
bacon
i'm going to ignore that last part
i am psyched thank you
oh that's the day after my birthday what
comes out of my birthday oh keena
am i saying that right it is kinah right
in a bridge of spirits
i think so cool with it
this is usually the moment when i say
hello i agree it looks
nice and outdated at the same time we
love that we can share the stage with
xbox this year
and whether you've known bethesda for 35
years or are just getting to know us
we couldn't be happier to bring you the
latest on your favorite games
we started this showcase i really
thought maybe i'd be okay we gave you a
first look
at starfield maybe with bethesda game
studios all of our teams are continuing
to work on the projects
that have been in development since well
before we joined the xbox family
so rest assured the games you've been
expecting and hoping for
are still in the works and today we're
bringing 10 more titles to game pass
for a total of 30 bethesda games cool
that includes several in software games
like the award-winning do maternal if
you're looking for another one already
do maternal will be optimized for xbox
series
on june 29th great this next-gen upgrade
will be free for everyone who owns stu
maternity
and on series x it will offer improved
visuals at 60 fps
with raid tracing i'm going to hopefully
she's going to talk about games i've
already played
performance mode please just keep
talking about dude please or maybe
you're in the mood for an rpg
like skyrim i played that that's great
it's 10th anniversary
this november we can't celebrate it
without you so share your favorite
skyrim memories
stories artwork and more on skyrim
10.com or
explore an ever-changing
post-apocalyptic wasteland
in fallout 76 everything you love about
fallout games
custom camp building rich story lines
warring factions unique characters
places to discover you'll find it all
here in fact
also played football it's great now it's
great more of the popular games
thanks to an incredibly welcoming and
collaborative community
here's a look at what's coming next in
fallout 76 new content okay i could
still blow my nose for this
brotherhood of steel under guardians of
human civilization
fort atlas is safe it came at a great
cost
the brotherhood must stand united
the super mutant threat takes priority
this proves more than anything the need
for our justice sorry everybody i'll do
my best
you're splitting our forces [ __ ] so i
ended up the most
important thing is finding everyone that
is having a fair amount of fun
76 especially playing at the fun house
even though i know so it comes to this
it's
[Music]
bad um i thought
i played with my friends
i'm not like excited about this content
for it but i did end up having a fair
amount of fun
i set this plan in motion playing on a
lot of locks for sure
a lot of things that i thought were cool
or interesting the brotherhood of steel
must protect the future of appalachia
and of the world a righteous crusade has
gone
too far well it may seem that we are
fragile
this is a choice that can never be
undone
glad that all this content's free
what the hell was that
expedition squad delta report over
squad delta what's going on out there
it's fable finally
so
that's actually pretty cool people do
love that pit
the wasteland isn't the only open world
playground with an amazing community
the elder scrolls online from xenomax
online studios has now surpassed
18 million players and shows no signs
because it's something that i like
players are enjoying the new blackwood
chapter
part no anyone who plays them um we've
got a lot more to come in esl
including the conclusion to this epic
story later this fall
with eso deadlines and with the release
of eso console enhanced
this tuesday the game will deliver a
true native experience
optimized for the series x and s
i really should like i have actually
played a few hours of it i played it
when it came to console
um which is a bizarre thing to say about
an mmo that we needed someone in
june at the time to give it a try so i
did
and yeah it was cool with it but never
kept up with it
[Music]
um
oh yeah for sure it wouldn't be 18
million
it does seem like everyone likes it a
lot
[Music]
it's a new world with new rules
now nothing is off the table winning
this battle
will take a new breed of fighter
wait
what's the name of this game oh
i don't know what it's called but it's
wonderful
[Music]
what is it ah [ __ ]
it's very very good i'm assuming that
this isn't a ripoff of the game that i'm
thinking of because if it is it's no
it's totally same
um just with very good new skins
[Music]
corgi no it might be gun beasts
i think it is
i mean these levels look
really good too
it is a very very fun game so aggressive
beat the [ __ ] out of omaha
[Music]
again unless it's a game that is human's
full flat you might be right it's one of
those two my head's like oh and i'll put
the i don't remember
this it's not that's nuts then
if it isn't one of uh what's the game
i'm [ __ ] thinking of then that is
just a
blatant ripoff if it's not by the same
studios
that's wild
[Music]
animals
[Music]
if this is not made by the same studio
as gang beasts
then what the hell
it's not wow
you love to see it hades is fantastic oh
it's game pause i'm covering the little
gameplay
this should be okay right surely
[Music]
i am like shocked that that game wasn't
wasn't getting me oh
i think this is a thing that we had seen
before
[Music]
the xbox chat is awful
oh no you killed that dog i swear to god
i had to leave ebony in my bed
at 2 30 a.m she did not seem stoked
about it
uh it did say hades is coming to get
possible
[Music]
and if you haven't had
i didn't expect that
[Music]
she looks like ellie from the last of us
and he looks like broccoli
and he
looks like nondescript child
cool that is one of those games and i'm
like yep i will also play that great
this holiday marks the 20th anniversary
of xbox
and the 20th anniversary of halo to our
millions of passionate fans
thank you we wouldn't be here without
all of you let's go
let's go our goal has always been i
would like to see an entire halo
and for the first time we're thrilled to
offer our entire multiplayer experience
to all players across xbox and pc with
no barriers
halo infinite multiplayer will be free
to play
and invite more of you than ever before
i am
i'm excited to be here with joseph
staton the creative director of halo
infinite
from helping craft the original halo
combat evolve
to leading the fan favorite halo 3 odst
joseph is a halo visionary it is so
great to have him back
with halo thank you bonnie and hey
everybody
for us and i hope many of you halo has
always been about heroism
and wonder about fighting to keep
humanity safe mostly against impossible
defense
in a beautiful and mysterious sci-fi
world you asked me what halo is about i
would not say heroism this
is just one world technically correct
it's not what my head would go to the
largest most wide open environment
we've ever built and we can't wait for
you to explore it
i'm not i don't even feel like i can say
anything about this because last time i
was like wow
it looks really pretty um halo infinite
because i thought it looked good
and everyone else disagree 117 the
master chief
in the next chapter of the chief's story
you'll face his greatest challenge yet
but they're not alone in the fight
the main batteries are shut down we're
stuck out here
who was that there was another trailer
that was like one of the politicians
trailers
or was it type of what can you do on
your own i told you
nice it's enough
so i see
[Music]
i need you to understand
there's not much
what happened where is cortana
the rogue ai known as cortana is gone
she's been deleted
how by you of course not
did you hit your head or something don't
you remember
my instructions were to enter this
installation imitate cortana and lock
her down for retrieval
yours were to take her back to the
infinity for deletion interesting
so if it wasn't you
okay then
there's something else that's how they
on successful deployment
my deletion routine was supposed to
complete
still here good
good something stopped your deletion
fisa looks rad we need to find out why
but this wasn't the mission the missions
changed
they always do are you sure
i got you a gift this is sd card
oh he's just putting girls in the back
of his head you know
of course you can't have a single game
without multiplayer it looks good and on
xbox series x
you'll be able to enjoy infinite's
multiplayer action at up to 120 frames
per second
finally i'm very happy to announce that
halo infinite's first
free-to-play multiplayer season and
infinite story-driven campaign
will launch together this holiday
still the release date of it's upon a
new
generation built to fight
together we are unstoppable
are you ready
it's gonna change things it's not like
it's gonna change things like too much
because you're already so
floaty cheap jumping buttons jumping you
know
yeah you're maybe like you know you
probably can't use grappling hooks if
you've got a gravity camera right
[Music]
that's a great example of how i'm never
going to play
return it to base
[Music]
that one got me right there
the flag is ours what a map
please call us at your earliest
convenience
that was cool
show me what you can do
that's sick but again
i feel like i'm not allowed to say it
because i said it looked sick last time
everyone got so upset with me
i maintain i think halo infinite looks
dope
i don't care about craig you know i
don't care
it looks super fun oh my god
i'm i can't wait
it's just something about it it looks
like so old school halo and that's what
gets me i love it and i'm
i'm yeah i'm stuck the dark figure
wanders in the east
he must be stopped
at all costs
nobody plays that good none of us
oh that's diablo
it's fair they are allowed to claim that
title i won't take it
um no robert edison the game i was
thinking of is definitely more like egg
beasts and not like fall guys
you are wrong i disagree definitely gang
beasts
[Music]
hear me
people have always asked me if uh i was
a cosplayer as anyone
that would be who it would be
but yes uh diablo 2
the remaster coming to console is of
absolutely no surprise to me
and is neat it's a great game maybe
that'll encourage more people who've
never
played diablo 2 before to play it it is
absolutely one of the kings of the genre
from all of us
a thousand times over from what we do to
him
can you stop it i don't know
but he's my brother and i would die for
[Music]
him
[Music]
is
[Music]
all their rats are they just rats
[Music]
not sure
gross stuff super cross oh that's a
pretty background
that is all very pretty
not that the first one wasn't pretty
graphically but
i would love to play morrow playtale
hell
yes let's do it that first game is
really good i only played it because
austin on the podcast kept uh
recommending it
that's awesome on board
okay why did you specify that after this
one in particular drinks every hour
oh yeah i haven't caught up on no you'll
be of course
i ended up having a very big family
yesterday was pretty much non-stop
let me ask you a question family time so
i skipped on you besides i am dead i
have attraction
what exactly is your plan hold hands
sing songs around the fire sure
i know just this song
i don't know why they're doing what does
that mean
[Music]
stealth operation i got you covered
[Music]
i have always loved playing [ __ ] with
a book it is very funny
[Music]
taking out a high value target i have
just what you need
[Music]
you want to blow [ __ ] up juan cortez at
your service
[Music]
and this is how it goes
there's nothing about this that's making
me feel any differently about wait a
second who brought the rooster
oh just forgot i take it all back
nope the game just went up a notch
absolutely
i apologize we disrespected them
next time i see you i want to play with
that crazy bag
[Music]
we have to get perfect off like i
recognize that it's probably too early
to get table games playing because
that's what i want
surely we'll get the dog i'm just
looking at the time it's been 49 minutes
so do i surely perfect time surely
you know combat rooster hit different
[Music]
you've had a pretty good variety
[Music]
it's like reverse catamaran
[Music]
do
[Music]
and we're into two oh it's just called
slime wrenching no
that is what i expected cool
[Music]
i never played the first one but
i don't know that it's my kind of game i
feel like maybe i should give it a try
if it's on game possibly gas
why not give it a shot maybe i'll love
it i have no idea
punch welcome back to shred again
here's a new trick let's go
i did used to absolutely [ __ ] love
snowboard games
i have one on the 64.
it doesn't look like steep to me because
that also wouldn't be fun punch
[Music]
i don't imagine it
could be ssx
it's not like we haven't had a number of
different kinds of snowboarding
franchise fish
[Music]
it must be hard to make a trailer first
no one again because everyone's like
yeah
we kind of know what you do they are fun
though they really are
shredders cool okay this is good this is
good this is really good
holy fluttering whiplash
[Music]
has a 2021 release date neat
people in the xbox chat were saying
skate did you really think so
there's something wrong about it i don't
know if that was skate
[Music]
foreign
i feel like i should know what this is
[Music]
but i don't think i do i really feel
like i should know what this is
hmm looked rad
it was like a very bioshocky
i'm appreciating the back to back to
back-to-back video games that's for sure
i feel like the bethesda conferences are
actually always very good at that
xbox has been a bit too talky sometimes
for sure
minecraft too finally doing it
oh my god speaking of games that will
never exist
too
[Music]
i like this trailer
is a very appealing trailer
[Music]
oh could this be that cyberpunky um
what was it lost to you i don't think it
looks like that though
i think it might be
[Music]
damn this looks cool
[Music]
also the music choice is fantastic
[Music]
replaced that was sick dude what the
[ __ ] was that
oh my god
hey i would love to learn more about the
first year of grounded
grounded is cool millions of players
kept
busy
with crafting
fighting the pond
ziplining flying
things now
to celebrate we present
the shroom and doom update it gives the
people what they've been asking for
like sitting no seriously a lot of
people want to sit
i never felt like i wanted to sit in
that game
and of course mushrooms
but not those kinds we've also got
something
that literally no one was asking for
mother no she's so
terrifying oh god
you should probably turn on
arachnophobia mode this is a creature
even her blob scares the [ __ ] out of us
no i think i'd still be scared
i really really like grounded i think
it's really fun it's very cheap
and i'm so scared of spiders which is
um but i like that balance of finding
something cute and exciting and also
it looks like we added achievements too
hey great nice
cool awesome glad to glad to hear about
updates for that
welcome finally everybody gets to spam
among us
that's what they all want
daniel said imagine this [ __ ] in vr
isn't grounded [ __ ] no dude i would
rather imagine
anything else what is wrong with you
hell no that is a good question
ethan why does every game depict russia
as a wasteland that is probably
a war era thing
about a potential outcome
coming soon cool with it i'd still think
among us
is extremely fun
that's too many creeds looking up info
about
replace is
[Music]
are these two separate games
i'm really unsure oh thank you george i
appreciate that
i liked it so much you gotta do it has
to be done
[Music]
[Music]
cool
you have shown an aptitude for applying
lethal solutions to conflicted
situations
we wish to test your abilities
sweet also looks cool a lot of cyberpunk
vibes
i'm into it these are vibes i enjoy
history is all around us
those who made it have never been
forgotten
[Music]
their daring choices echo across time
turning land into kingdoms and
mortals into legends
if history was in your hands
what would you build
that's what i suspected i was like
there's no way that
this is a date of advice
what game looks that realistic hell no
where would you go
what would you be remembered for i
played
a lot of empires as a kid like a ton
because it was one of the few games that
my sister and i got in like a cereal box
or in a magazine or something
um and i'm pretty sure it was the full
game but i just remember like all the
cheats and
all of the sound effects i [ __ ] loved
it but then i
completely stopped playing any game in
the genre after i was reading
seven [ __ ] terrible at them now
not a genre i enjoy but i loved
um or did love age of empires 1 000
times over
very cool maybe i should maybe i should
do it
we have 62 minutes in i don't know how
long this is supposed to be is it an
hour and a half
that wouldn't surprise me
we taken it to 90. we haven't even seen
phil by hearing an old
wise sounding voice
when we see a quiet peaceful setting
this is fable
this will make our game seem big this is
totally gotta be fatal come on now
something must break the serenity
no maybe not will this creature be in
the game
maybe it is this is something say
goodbye to it forever
some british ass humor and for no reason
people running now
only one thing we must gaze
over an epic shot of a world and there
should be
lens flares now
we see our hero but only the silhouette
because the developers haven't finished
the design
or finished the story or finished any
gameplay
that's actually ready to show in fact
the only thing
they have finished
is the title
no way
what oh my god i did not see that coming
wow what a great trailer for a fantastic
studio
damn that was cool hell yeah
i am on board i really like ottawa
[Music]
want some really updates
[Music]
i mean i'd be very surprised
if it's anything else i'm shocked
[Music]
pretty sure it is
[Music]
forza what
[Music]
is that an update i wouldn't know enough
about the game to tell you what's
different in that but it looked pretty
cool i did find it very impressive what
i played of it
[Music]
oh is this what the new content is
[Music]
oh wow it's a top gun dying
sorry everybody i'm tweeting about outer
worlds too
there we go
okay
thank you wild
the last guest was hellblade but i
suspect not held right now
red dead redemption 3 ladies and
gentlemen can't believe they've dropped
it on us here
out of nowhere joking
oh that makes sense it's a forza
[Music]
they did say this is an engine and um
the least hot take i've ever had is
wow looks very good
the environments are [ __ ] gorgeous
tell me what you want right now
[Music]
let everybody talk right now tell me
what you want right now
you can get it
it's beautiful it's absolutely beautiful
so this is a horizon
because obviously we had also
[Music]
i've played every single horizon game
and i will continue to do so though i
didn't play anywhere near as much of the
last one as i should have
i feel like i touch it really frequently
hello and put it down i'm mike brown
creative director at playground games
and i can't wait
to show you what we've been working on
horizon is known for fun
freedom and beauty and this year the
horizon festival arrives in beautiful
diverse mexico footsteps is the largest
and most diverse open world
it's a horizon game it's basically just
an arcade racer
in parallel detail and with ray tracing
in forza vista
thanks to the power it's i feel like
it's relatively serious
i've invited along some of the team to
help give you a taste of some of the
amazing content
that's waiting for you in forza horizon
5.
please welcome bill maddie sierra and
don from the forza team
hey mike hey guys what's up hey everyone
hey what's up mike
and we also have abraham with us as well
he is one of the talented actors
appearing in the game
i can't wait to show you what we've been
working on we begin in the rainforest
setting expedition this is a new
campaign mode
in which you set out on an adventurous
journey across mexico
to explore new locations for the
festival
[Music]
there you are how's the expedition going
streamless making
i'm racing a car through the white house
doesn't get much better than this
i hope it's the street
that's a peek at our adventurous
campaign but forza horizon has always
been a game that's best enjoyed with
others
let's go and see
the xbox series consoles allow us to
capture every last detail
right down to the individual needles on
these troya cactus
the scene looks real but there are no
tricks
pretty much this is in-game maddie is
behind the wheel of the amg
project one forza edition in mexico's
lush
living desert the perfect place to meet
up with friends and head out
for a drive thanks to the next
generation of our horizon live servers
everyone else we see here are real
players and it looks like maddie has
been joined by some
other members of the forza team
you guys don't need to talk it's okay i
don't i don't need this
please take a moment and head out to the
coast and meet don
don is already on the move exploring
this idyllic
seaside town this is a recreation of
mexico that is honest
authentic and filled with love speaking
of hold up don
oh hey what's up this is a mural by
mexican artist farid rueda
just one of the many beautiful faithful
pieces of mexico
you'll find all over forza horizon 5.
art is like kind of collectible
while don drives down to the beach we'll
jump over to the grand caldera volcano
check out this geology details
implemented with precision accuracy
using photogrammetry data captured
the entire world has been recreated at
this level of detail
and here's sierra in her favorite
off-road boogie
the volcano sierra and friends are
exploring is the highest point ever in a
horizon game
and thanks to the power of the xbox
series consoles
from up here we can see for miles in
every direction
in the distance we can just about make
out guanajuato
let's take a closer look guanajuato
is one of the most beautiful cities
anywhere in the world
it's a colorful undulating city full of
vibrant architecture
and these twisting turning overlapping
struts i mean as well as looking good it
plays great too
as we see here as don is challenged in
horizon's open world battle royale
the eliminator what while don tries to
win that race
the rest of our players are still out
exploring this diverse
open world let's head north to the
canyon
the horizon series is known for its
uplifting dude
these environments are using our unique
hdr camera rig
we captured 24-hour shoots of real
mexican skies at 12k
resolution and thanks to the xbox series
consoles
these photo realistic skies result in
lifelike lighting that dynamically
changes every frame is really really
the new ai assistant that intelligently
tracks the status of you
and the people you meet online and then
helps you link up and play together
we'll now head deep into the rainforest
and rejoin bill and the rest of our
players
here we see our new volumetric lighting
system filling the scene with god rays
as the sunlight dapples through the
dense rainforest
a horizon arcade mini game is about to
start
winning knows that bill loves minigames
it must be their secretary
prompts sierra to win but i wouldn't
even thought this was actually street
this is
linked together with that horizon arcade
mini game starting soon
all of our players are coming together
this mini game is called pinata pop
signaled by the horizon cargo plane
dropping a payload of pinatas that would
be fun
there's some between the houses there's
some between the houses hope
there's a couple more over here sweet
while the team grabbed those last few
pinatas
we're going over to the stadium because
i have one more to show you
cool this is probably a little bit
longer than it should be for the
competitors of the show this is really
impressive
to create your own races game modes and
gameplay experiences
you customize everything right down to
the fundamental rules
of the game like gta
finally funhouse can stop playing gta
they can move on to forza horizon forza
horizon 5
is the largest most fun and most
beautiful open world
we've ever built i'm feeling you and it
will truly be an astounding showcase for
the xbox series consoles
when it comes to xbox game pass this
november 9th
very cool thank you so much i'm really
surprised i'll see you all in mexico
later this year
it really is the only one that i haven't
like destroyed
barry is he's on a mission bringing the
join community of gaming to everyone on
the planet [ __ ] you for making you wake
up
4 15 a.m at the center of everything
today we showed you 30 games
27 will be available on xbox game pass
now through the end of the year you can
look forward to back
seven monthly releases landing day one
on game pass it's like wild to be like
oh i don't have the paper any titles
from xbox game studios
as well as highly anticipated games like
back for blood
12 minutes in the ascent and as we look
ahead to next year
i'm inspired by the creativity of
bethesda
and xbox game studios and now we
showed you the highly anticipated rpg
star
field you did coming exclusive still
don't know entirely what it is
but we also have some of the industries
rpg storytellers
working on avow fable yeah we don't know
fallout 76 the outer worlds 2
and elder scrolls 6. we unveiled the
stunning multiplayer
they didn't show the lions but that was
the show that was in summit game fest
they had nothing to the roster about
i'll be playing that next week some
gameplay up alongside
wolfenstein gears of war perfect dark
and dew we premiered the most epic
open world racing game forza horizon 5
bringing you a vibrant and authentic
mexico
in a game built from the ground up for
next gen
while the team at turn 10 is hard at
work on the next
forza motorsport intensive our growing
family of
23 studios is devoted to advancing
yeah yeah this is honestly yes that was
revealed last year
xbox has been here for 20 years and
that's because of
you strives to make xbox a place
where you'll find the greatest games the
most dedicated developers
and the most passionate community and
perfect dog together
we all make xbox the best place to play
before i go there's one more thing
take a look at this brand new original
game
from the arcane team at the studio that
created
prey one of my favorite studios in the
entire world
kane created something new for them an
open world
immersive shooter that you can play
alone
or with your friends it can't be
definitely like starting though i
imagine that will end up coming out
will be an xbox exclusive
i'm gonna have to take you apart again
hey dove
anything else yes is this two handable
25 centimeters but also
you can totally tell their faces are all
so obvious if you smell the games
so uh that was fun right
i worry that obviously completely wrong
sleep time that this could be a game
that they would make
that is later down it is a uh it is a um
back for blood type
um that they would make this game to
like fill in the gap before they can
have death loop which means that it's
probably not
obviously making millions but not
necessarily
[ __ ] is that laura bailey
what is the problem in the field in red
for massachusetts
behind me we are witnessing clear signs
of
cult activity as the locals engage
influences man
i really hope the video was worth it
i think that might be worse people need
to
[Music]
in which case it looks like it would be
very fun
because the heroes have kind of more
dramatic abilities yeah like he's going
to be a tank right
big scary vampire boy where's the other
one
vampires may be hot is that a new
concept did i just come up with that am
i original
jacob
oh [ __ ] dad's gonna love this one
while space survival shooter seems fair
yeah
that's somebody's alt a new one
i think there's a vampire in this really
what does it taste like be specific like
blood and
death and strawberry sun's coming up
let's keep moving let's keep moving
sure thing edgar allen bro surely it is
like a leopard
so obviously i want single-player
experiences from them i
cannot [ __ ] wait for deathly um
decided
and two and fray fantastic red fall
but that looks really fun it does look
really fun
and is that it
[Music]
yeah it's a it's a four-player co-op
and i will play it and i will have a
good time playing it thank you
he's gonna be out our ending sizzle
trailer thingy
[Music]
i really enjoyed the pacing of this
conference
[Music]
it's very possible
there's not much talking which you love
to see
bring me that horizon if we can
i think that's awesome
[Music]
[Music]
it's a lot of game boss games it's neat
[Music]
i think this is probably the time that i
should get back in the age of empire so
i've been saying that foreign
[Music]
might be my most
most excited actual individual
announcement here
i'm pretty stoked about that all right
that's it everybody
um i think i might go sleep
until five and then
come back to square enix
are you doing where was this
it's just it's just an ad it's just an
ad um
replaced with my my favorite trailer
oh the fridge
oh my god that's funny
[Music]
i'm into it
oh my god very nice
i hope that they are actually
purchasable and don't all just sell out
immediately
so ridiculous
oh my gosh um
yeah stoked about the playtale
announcement really really really liked
the replaced trailer
i thought the obsidian one was fun i
think halo being free to play is a very
good idea
in such a competitive
multiplayer landscape
[Music]
but uh yeah i think i'm gonna take a
really quick nap before we come back to
square eggs
so thank you all for joining me for this
one um bummed we didn't get perfect dark
or fable but i understand they are
probably pretty far away
um i don't feel like i have any other
particularly
pressing thoughts other than wow forza
was pretty pretty unsurprisingly
um alrighty i will be back for square
enix
at 5 15 which is about 45 minutes away
i will see you guys then